it's not just a boycott right now
Anheuser-Busch is accused of racist and
sexist hiring practices that prioritized
minorities in complaint filed by Trump
advisors Legal Group during the Dylan
Mulvaney firestorm
you know Anheuser-Busch could have just
stayed out of this whole thing
after they accidentally stepped in it
they could have just apologized they
didn't and now not only are they being
targeted by the view Whoopi Goldberg
they're now facing a lawsuit from
America First legal they say the group
claimed that companies are using the
cloak of equity to proudly discriminate
based on race color national origin and
sex in their Employment Practices AFL
who's President and America first
legal's president and CEO is a former
Trump advisor Stephen Miller
sent a complaint letter to the St Louis
Missouri office for the EEOC requesting
an investigation into anheuser-busch's
programs amazing look at this what is
this Brewing scholarship
developed in partnership with uncf the
annual scholarship program supports 25
black college students pursuing degrees
ranging from business to food science
that could lead to a career in the
Brewing industry so is is that what
they're being targeted like is these uh
scholarships
they say one is the leadership
accelerator program which advises at
which advertises that it provides formal
mentorship executive interaction and
leadership development curriculum for
those who identify with historically
underrepresented groups as they join our
organization in a full-time capacity it
only encourages people of black Native
American and Latino Origins to apply
there you go this is not a regular
corporate program rather the company
describes the role as focusing on hiring
the next generation of leaders within
the North American sustainability and
procurement Department in other words it
is a fast track program to Executive
leadership positions at Anheuser-Busch
and it is limited to candidates based on
race the pro forma equal opportunity
employer language at the end of the
posting does mask the company's
discriminatory intent and purpose
interesting now they're getting hit over
what basically tons of companies are
doing but good on the America First
legal I guess these diversity quotas are
nothing new and affirmative action
surely isn't new and when those were
created they weren't supposed to last
this long but now it's created what I
basically call Black privilege where we
are given all these opportunities just
because of the color of our skin and I
feel like it's such an outdated concept
that it shocks me that you still have
companies that are going so out of their
way to push for minorities as if
minorities can't be successful on our
own right it's honestly insulting to me
and I feel like it's going to continue
until I honestly feel like white people
are going to have their own version of
like a civil rights movement just
because these racist things just keep
happening in these companies I I think
it's going to result in heightened
racial tension people fighting and then
you've already seen people claiming to
be like white Rights Movement like stuff
like this several years and they're
making these arguments like hey you know
a poor white dude who wants to go to
college shouldn't have barriers placed
in front of them in response to me he
just says you're a white supremacist
that was so bad like all of it all of it
and like the idea of like having people
start having people start having white
people start saying we need a white
you know uh affinity group and and have
to have that kind of stuff for white
people that is a terrible idea it's a
horrible idea but if only because the
left is going to say racist and
everyone's gonna believe it and you're
gonna look like absolute like straight
up cross-burning racist and it's very
hard to get rid of these programs
because not only do they get employees
like like Donald Glover got hired at NBC
for cheap because he was hired through
like a diversity Excellence program
right and it comes with great publicity
because half their jobs are just going
to these luncheons where they go to the
you know and they go Pat each other on
the back and they lead to articles that
are written in trade magazine so they
get all this good publicity on top of
hiring someone that's subsidized so it's
very hard to get rid of those programs
in regards to White rights and all that
stuff I think it's I think it's a bad
idea for I I agree with you Phil but at
the same time
we're getting to a point where if you
want to get into certain universities
they're they're they're giving benefits
to People based on race and it's making
it harder for so so look at this way
they want at these universities what
they claim is called racial parity where
it's like okay so if the country is 13
black seven percent Asian you know
whatever that's what's going to be in
the schools but that's not what's
happening what's happening is they're
giving like 20 20
and so certain people of certain races
are getting boosted up certain rates are
getting pushed down Asians especially
are getting pushed down don't be
surprised then if you start seeing
groups of people who claim to be white
rights and they're not white
supremacists you like you there's a
distinction a white supremacist a person
who thinks that they're race is superior
versus a white rights person who's
making the argument that like hey I'm
I'm a lower income Carpenter my kid
wants to go to college and they're
saying he can't yeah and now you're
gonna get that those people making those
advocacy groups you know the D you were
talking about the default left this
morning today on one of the things that
default left is going to hear that and
they're going to think racist they're
not gonna matter I know but that's going
to make America worse it's going to make
people it's like yeah but this is just
to me Domino's falling over yeah you're
you're not so you've already seen the
Asian groups coming out because of
Harvard and affirmative action stuff the
SAT scores for like the average agent
has to be like you have to score like
1300 because they're like well there's
too many Asian people which is in my
opinion insane if you get if you pass
pass
and so yeah you're gonna start seeing
more and more of these groups of people
maybe they'll try and mask it they'll
call it like Irish affiliation or
something like that but it's going to be
some kind of white rights thing you're
going to see lawsuits like this they're
going to be called white supremacist but
I will say
perhaps the reason we won't see those
groups forming is because Republicans
are too scared of the left so they won't
call it that they'll call it America
First legal you know where I'm not
arguing that America First legal is
fighting on behalf of white people I'm
saying they're going to give it names
like the the American Pride you know
rights organization there's the word
Patriot has been turned into something
that they find to be despicable they're
synonymous with racism they're trying to
do that with the Betsy Ross flag
absolutely
we'll try to who was it like with Colin
Capron who got that shoe yeah I think I
think it was yeah and it's like it was I
I know there were people I definitely
responded with a picture of Barack Obama
with the Betsy Ross flag behind him when
he was inaugurated it's like give me a
break founding flash so ridiculous I
mean they still do the same thing with
the Gadsden flag and you have to explain
to them that it has nothing to do with
that that it was a revolutionary but
they're lying on purpose no yeah they're
just trying to trample over the things
that remind people of what this country
was founded upon but the gazden flag is
individuality you know and and resisting
tyranny Liberty and things like that and
they want to turn Liberty into fascism
they they lie cheat and they steal
that's what they do and that's why they
win because they have no morals and
because they they have no problem with
breaking the rules if it means that
they're we were just talking about this
today okay they they have race swapped
uh or they've made a colorist move for
the casting and Lilo and Stitch it
sounds off but it tracks okay so the
they casted a woman who is uh not
Polynesian to play a character to play
lilo's mom in Lilo and Stitch right and
they don't care and the lady basically
makes the argument says it's okay to
race swap Ariel in The Little Mermaid
because it benefits black people to now
have representation in this field but it
doesn't benefit a minority group if we
do it this way they literally just admit
it doesn't matter if we're being
hypocritical yes we're right because our
end goal is more righteous that's the
logic right that is the logic of the
left exactly yes yeah I'm pretty sure
that woman that got Castle was actually
Polynesian she's just I think Polynesian
and part white so they were saying that
she just wasn't dark she's
um Filipino I believe I don't believe
she's Polynesian but she's born in
Hawaii so she's by all for all intents
and purposes that's why they're not
calling it racist they're calling it
colorist so it's different it's about
Shades not about actual racial makeup so
there's one thing that I want to point
out like people talk about there's a lot
of people talking about critical race
Theory and everyone was saying oh blah
blah I don't know what it was and it's
not this or whatever
they're one of the things that that
critical race Theory talks about is
having a critical Consciousness awoken
critical racial Consciousness when you
awaken a critical racial Consciousness
in white people they they essentially
are saying look you should feel bad
that's the whole uh the white fragility
but the book makes that argument there's
gonna be an amount of people that are
gonna be like well I don't feel bad you
know and they're going to be like well
okay so now I'm gonna have a white
affinity group and I'm going to join it
and I'm not going to feel bad and Jordan
Peterson made this argument you know six
seven years ago that like there's going
to be a cert if you focus on race all
the time which is the illiberal thing to
do the liberal thing to do the the
Enlightenment ideas is that the
individual matters if you focus on the
individual you'll be fine but if you
focus on Races then races are going to
start to to do it more and more and it's
it ends up creating more and more
segregation in your in your Society it's
a terrible idea they hate focusing on
the individual yeah they do
I mean I feel like that's what they're
already doing because I always call
critical race Theory just critically
looking for racism into everything where
we're told as young children especially
as a young black kid you're told to look
at the differences between the person or
you and the people next to you instead
of realizing like oh we have so much in
common we have all these different
cultural aspects that might be different
but they're cool we can learn about each
other's cultures instead we're told to
basically hate our neighbor hate the
person next to us if they're not the
same color as us I don't understand how
anybody can feel that that is productive
to put us in the minds of kids and you
know it's not because these educators
are hiding it in curriculum they're
calling it all kind of other things
they're calling it ethnic studies or
sometimes they just call it something
that has nothing to do with CRT but
they're still putting it in the
curriculum thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time